welcome back to crypto.com Arena this
Series has certainly been electric on
the floor and it's bled a little bit
into the post-game comments because
Dylan Brooks he said that LeBron James
is old and that he won't respect him
until he gives him 40. so this is how
fans and crypto.com Arena greeted him
today in warm-ups
[Applause]
well they let him know how they feel
immediately and Dylan Brooks who his
credit has fully embraced the role of
whatever you want to characterize it as
maybe heal
um but I'll tell you this about Brooks
he needs everything to Memphis in terms
of
their defense and their intensity and
told me a little bit earlier coming up
in the game he modeled his defense
scores after Ron Artest back in the day
liked his rugged and feisty style of
guarding high scores on the other end
there are times I think he crosses the
line
I respect highly what this guy does
nightly and in listening to Desmond Bain
talk about his teammate
and the rest of the guys they respect
that this guy is digging it out of the
dirt he does not bring Elite athleticism
to the game uh he obviously does not
bring Elite shooting he's on the floor
to do one thing guard the toughest guy
every single night it's a thankless job
it's a hard job and he Embraces it
meanwhile when asked about it says you
can miss me with all that stuff
in different language of course Brooks
misfiring on another three rebounded by
Davis
[Applause]